en france les ministres de l'éducation
nationale monsieur savary va rendre
public dans quelques jours une série de
propositions sur les rapports entre
l'enseignement privé et l'état et à
cette occasion une vingtaine de
personnalités viennent de lancer un
appel aux chrétiens pour la paix
scolaire
il se déclare convaincu qu'un dialogue
sur la question scolaire est possible et
nécessaire
déjà mercredi une importante
manifestation avait eu lieu à quimper où
les partisans de l'école privée étaient
descendus dans la rue pour soutenir la
grève de la faim d'un directeur
d'établissement nouvel élément à verser
au dossier
les déclarations du père guiberteau le
secrétaire général de l'enseignement
catholique
il passe pour un modéré estime que les
négociations sont bien nécessaires mais
il a précisé à dominique le riz les
points qui selon lui ne sont pas
négociables
on ne veut pas céder sur le choix libre
des parents par rapport à l'école on ne
peut pas céder sur l'autonomie des
établissements dans l'expression de leur
vie associative et on ne peut pas céder
sur les conséquences c'est-à-dire
finalement le projet d'un établissement
qui chez nous est de nature
confessionnelle avec ses conséquences
sur le choix du directeur et sur le
choix des enseignants
est-ce que vous pensez que malgré ces
restrictions
il est possible de créer un grand
service public et laïque d'éducation
alors nous voulons être clairs sur la
signification de ces termes
avant de répondre nous demandons au
gouvernement de nous préciser son projet
définitif jusqu'à maintenant c'était pas
clair pour nom le 20 décembre il nous a
pas semblé soul et que ces réalités été
clairement exprimée au contraire il nous
a paru que ce qui était clairement
exprimé c'était une volonté
d'assimilation à l'enseignement public
et d'intégration de nos établissements
et parents sont inquiets les parents
sont inquiets mais il y a bien sûr des
mouvements ici ou là d'ailleurs le
on prend parfaitement étant donné les
difficultés de la rentrée les refus d'un
certain nombre de sections donc il y à
une fermeté qui s'expriment mais ça
n'est pas encore la guerre quand vous
dites que ce n'est pas encore la guerre
cela sous-entend que la guerre pourrait
se déclencher
nous voulons vivre et si on nous coupait
toute possibilité de vivre il est bien
évident que nous n'aurions pas d'autres
réactions que que de manifester dans le
pays
notre volonté de vivre et demandé le
soutien de l'opinion publique
c'est une menace ou c'est un conseil
c'est à la fois un conseil et c'est peut
être une menace dans la mesure où
effectivement nous arrivons au bout des
échéances